.
Bonne chance.
- Au revoir.
maintenant, tout près de Kiev,
une mère de famille qui est
en train de vivre en direct
ces événements. Olga Rogoza,
bonsoir.
- Vous êtes enseignante de
français, vous avez deux
enfants, vous vivez à Kiev,
éloigner de la ville. Où êtesvo?
- Je suis à la campagne à 100 km
- Votre marie n'est pas avec
vous. Où est-il? Et que fait-il?
- Il est
Il a décidé de résister et
il est allé rejoindre la défense
territoriale. Et voilà donc,
en ce moment, il surveille
- Est-ce qu'il a une compétence
est ce qu'il connaît
ment des armes?
- Non, il est informaticien
de métie
une kalashnikov et voilà, donc,
je penseppris à
la manipuler. Et puis voilà.
- Qu'est ce qui l'faire ça, Mme?
- Bien, c'est le sentiment de...
je sais pas... c'est quelque
chose, c'est notre terre, c'llee
qu'on doit défendre, tout
simplement parce qu'on a de
la famille ici. Vous savez,'on
éprouve contre les Russes, c'est
la haine, donc tout ce qui se
passe, on pouvait même pas
imaginer il y a deux jours.
une autre vie pour
Il y a deux jours, on avaitut ds
les grandes villes. Moi, j'ai
enseigné à l'université, lui il
allait au travail,
allaient à l'école. Mais là,,
tout simplement. C'est comme
dit : "Bien, c'était dans une
autre vie". On a l'impression
qu'on a vécu déjà au moins
de la guerre. Donc voilà, voilà
le sentiment, c'est parce que
c'est... on ne peut pas faire
- Mais il va affronter
votre mari, des soldats
professionnels, de
russes. Dans quel état d'esprit
e que vous êtes
très inquiète pour lui?
On le comprend très bien que
ce sont des soldats russes
professionnels. Mais au moins,
de cette journée, la deuxième
journée de la guerre, montrent
que finalement, on arrive à
les arrêter. Parce que depuis
ce matin, il y a edes Russes qus
la villeats russes
des diversionnistes russes,
Ils ont été tués comme çasur ple
de Kiev, il a annoncé, j'ai
il y a quelques minutes, il a
annoncé que la nuit va être
très difficile et surtout, toute
à 21 heures, ils ont, 21 he
chez nous, ils ont annoncé qu'on
Et alors je suis avecmes copines
en "messenger" et tout le
monde... ils sont tous parti
r dans lesr dans lesr dans lesrs
les abris métro, les stations
de métro. Alors que je suis
affolée.a
campagne, c'est calme, j'entends
mais à Kiev, je suis toutle temr
"messenger" ou par téléphone.
qui se passe.
- Comment vos enfants vivent ça,
Mme Rogoza? De savoir queé affrr
les soldats russes à Kiev.
- Je leur ai expliqué.
J'essaieils le montrent peut êt.
. déjà, il a
15 ans, donc il comprend pas mal
inquiète, bien sûr, maisj'essaie
avec eux parce que les enfants
l'état des adultes. Donc je sais
me tenir en main, mais, c'est
vrai, c'est difficile. que vousz
la communauté internationale?
Comment vous le ressentez?
Comment vous voyez ça?
qui crie à l'aide carrément.
Qui dit : "Venez! Amenez
des troupes, venez noust vous,
comme citoyenne, v
- Bon, vous savez, j'avais pas
beaucoup
de l'aide européenne ou
a, on reçoit
pas mal d'armes, on suit ça
On parle beaucoup que l'Europe
nous envoie des armes et nous de
financière, mais c'est peu., co,
resté tout seul en tête-à-tête
qui était un pays énorme,deuxiè,
et nous, tout petits, quiça. Bid
que vous, que les Occidentaux
intervene
ça va signifier que c'estla Tro,
carrément. Mais au moins,
nous aider avec les armes ou...
Vous savez, dans les réseaux
sociaux, en ce moment,
on demande que tous
les Ukrainiens envoient
les messages parto
la demande de bouclier aérien,
donc, pour protéger le ciel.
Au moins comme ça parce
,
qu'on a annoncé, par exemple,
tout à l'heure, ça fait peur,
vraiment à Kiev. À Kiev,
qui est... c'est une très
grande ville. Et puis recevoir
des miss
Donc, bien sûr, si l'Occident
pourrait faire quelque chose,
au moins
déjà reconnaissants.
- Mme Rogoza, la nuit va être
longue.
- Ouais.
- On est de tout coeur avec
vous. Ce que vous vivez est
s, mère ds, mère ds, mère ds, me
famille, deux enfants,
le mari qui est parti sans
formation militaire, essayéde dt
sa ville. Merci infiniment
pour ce témoignage qui est
très précieux.
- Je vou